Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week one day early because of my
upcoming trip, remember, we're going to have
some great guest hosts upcoming, including
Faran Cousins from Ring of Fire and Fair
Balance, the eponymous named Fair and Balanced.
Also Jesse Dolma. It's going to be great. It's
going to be absolutely fantastic. But let's
get right into your questions. David, do you
think Joe Biden is really going to try to pass
a national vaccine mandate? The statement so far
from the White House have been confusing. Yeah. So
the White House, I think, is being careful.
There's been a couple of times now where White
House staffers have been asked about, is Biden
investigating? Is Biden planning for is he getting
advice about a possible vaccine mandate? And the
answer has been a pretty carefully worded that is
not something he is looking to do or has any plans
to do at this time. And of course, when I hear
that, I don't hear he's eventually going to do
it. I hear he's not ruling it out unconditionally
because circumstances may change and it's
conceivable that it makes sense to leave it
on the table. But I actually don't think the Biden
administration is going to even attempt to pass
a federal vaccine mandate. However, we've already
talked about the potential legality of state level
vaccine mandates and municipality level vaccine
mandates, and there does seem to be precedent
for it. You look at Cambridge, Massachusetts, in
the very early 20th century. I don't remember if
it was ninety five, ninety three. There
was a point where the city of Cambridge
said you must be vaccinated against smallpox.
The vaccine was, quote, experimental at the time,
much the same way that now the vaccines have
not yet received FDA approval, although they're
expected to soon. And so my guess would be that
if Joe Biden wanted to try to force people to be
vaccinated and again, that doesn't mean someone
shows up and holds you down. My guess is that
it would be some kind of requirement would,
I don't know, maybe a fine attached to it or
something. Even saying it doesn't really make any
sense, because I don't think it's going to happen.
I think the way Biden would do it is he would push
for governors or municipalities to mandate it,
which seems much more based in precedent, at
least from a legal standpoint. Now, I'll go
even further. I don't know that we're really
going to see that because I I think accurately
it's seen as likely political suicide for whoever
tries to do it. I think even in blue states with
Democratic governors, a vaccine mandate could
be a recipe for you lose your next reelection,
because I think it would not be well received
by enough people in basically every state
that it could be a really politically disastrous
thing to do. And so more plausible and maybe
equally effective is just look at the polling
where people say what would be most likely to
encourage them to get vaccinated. So as an
example, last week I covered this live event
where Joe Biden said, hey, governors, please use
the money we sent you to give one hundred dollars
to everybody who goes and gets a first shot. OK,
a poll was done on that over the weekend, and only
14 percent of Americans who are not interested
in the vaccine said one hundred dollars would
change their mind. 14 percent said I don't want
the vaccine, but for 100 bucks, I would go.
Contrast that with 41 percent of those who don't
currently want a vaccine, who said if it was
required to fly, I would go and get vaccinated.
It doesn't take that much thinking to realize Joe
Biden and the federal government through the FAA
have a lot of say over what happens on airplanes
and would there be a more effective approach than
mandating vaccines are giving people 100 bucks
then working through the FAA either to
directly or to encourage airlines to say
you must be vaccinated in order to fly with
us? Or at minimum, if you're not vaccinated,
you have to do a negative test. You could even
I think even that would significantly increase
vaccination numbers. Right now, when you fly
domestically, there might be some examples like I
know at one point Hawaii was doing something with
testing. Right now, though, to fly domestically,
you don't even need to be tested. So you could
even stop short of a vaccine requirement for for
aviation, domestic aviation. You could just
say you now have two options. When you fly,
you either bring proof of vaccination, which I
know some people will say, well, people will start
faking those. That's got to be punished. Really,
seriously, really, really seriously. The way
Canada punished a couple of Americans for faking
vaccine information, you either give us proof of
vaccination or you've got to get a test right here
or within 48, 72, however you figure it out, that
would make a really big dent in those who don't
want to get vaccinated go by. What people are
telling you is the point that I'm trying to make.
I don't expect Joe Biden to actually try a federal
vaccine mandate. I think if he wants to go in that
direction, it's likely he would say, governors,
please do this in your states. Of course, if he
did that. The governors that are willing to do it
are probably the ones in the states that are
already more vaccinated and less urgently would
need to do it, that's always that's sort of a
moral hazard, status quo type of thing. But that's
the way I see it. Let me know if you see the
likelihood of a Biden vaccine mandate differently.